we have to declare racism a public
health
crisis we already have sufficient data
to declare
structural races in the public health
crisis that it is racism is a public
health
crisis well the lefties they were
clamoring for it
and the cdc finally did it they caved
into the months-long campaign by the
left to declare racism a quote
serious public health threat forget
about covet 19 this is
absolutely what the cdc should be
focusing its time on right now they're
nailing it
they should focus on this the agency's
saying in a statement that racism quote
directly affects the well-being of
millions of americans
and the health of our entire nation
joining me now is dr ben carson founder
and chairman of the american cornerstone
institute and former hud
secretary doctor thank you very much for
joining us tonight
i got to ask you this in your expert
medical
opinion because those words should
matter is racism a serious public
health threat well you know it would be
funny if
it wasn't so serious pete and uh you
know
a few weeks ago you probably remember
the french said
the greatest danger facing them was
awoke
america i mean that's where the real
health crisis is going on i was looking
at a news story not too long ago
and they were interviewing college
students from other parts of the world
and one of the questions was would you
like to come to america
and they all said there was a time when
they wanted to
that time is passed what happened to the
shiny city on the hill
that was the goal for people all over
the world and we have to be very
concerned about what's going on right
now
you know america the idea not america
the place
it's so important as far as the cdc is
concerned
it used to be a place of science
where people did things based on
evidence and on facts
and when you start injecting politics
into it
it really damages the credibility of
that organization
and that's problematic for us all yes
in terms of our in terms of public
health that's the real hazard
injecting politics into science
yeah just like when you pack the court
you delegitimize an institution our
country
requires and needs uh same thing with
the cdc here
same thing with the word racism when you
call everything racist it dilutes the
actual meaning but
but when democrats actually act like
racists
it seems like they're forgiven for it
remember this
governor northam has led the most
forward-looking virginia
ever with real progress on our original
sin of racism
and with the abolition of the death
penalty so that's a representative
remember ralph northand was caught
wearing blackface and now he
single-handedly somehow removed
virginia's so-called original sin of
racism
so you can be forgiven if you
sufficiently bend to the woke folks
for for the mistakes you've made never
the other way around
well you know what is so serious here
is that we are doing exactly what needs
to be done
to move to socialism and communism
and that is replacing god
with government amen and as government
expands
as ronald reagan said our freedoms
decrease
that's what's really going on people
need to wake up
and you know that's why we developed
american cornerstone institute
so we can bring back those principles
remind people of who we are
as americans we you know a godly
principle
is to love your neighbor awoke principle
is to cancel your neighbor is that
really where we want to go
when you look down the road those two
pathways they lead to very different
places
we now still have a chance to change the
direction of this country
to save it for our children and our
grandchildren we need to stop being
selfish
that means also not massively raising
the debt
because who's going to have to pay that
not us older people we're going to be
dead and gone
it's going to be our children and our
grandchildren we're ruining their lives
that's not fair thomas jefferson said
it was immoral amen when we forget we
are all
sinners redeemed by grace then we start
pointing fingers in ways we never should
and then we can't walk back from it
i love the idea of the american
cornerstone institute it is about god
and thank you for continuing to talk
about it dr carson have a great evening
thank you appreciate